because you auditioned for sawhorses
Newkirk oh yeah years ago um you know
they were gonna do this movie and guys
my age were all going in to reforest
yeah I read for both parts actually for
Han Solo and Princess Leia yeah they
went in a different direction
yeah yeah it's funny because you know at
the time it was the Millennium Falcon
this and the Death Star that we had no
idea we were talking about it was just
so real that with them that was the
Death Star yes does this young guy you
know Lucas was about 25 or something
when he did you know I said I got to
make a choice here do you know if you're
gonna use me in this movie and he said I
just can't I can't there's a lot of
combinations that I'm looking at I don't
know and so I said I again I gotta go
cuz I got a bit of work oh yeah so what
do you do instead of Star Wars well I
didn't do it instead of Star Wars he may
not have used me though let's go with
you no you did it in soft give my please
God let it be a chin film I didn't turn
down any I'm Tina Fey you've given us
our your printer's laughs yeah I was a
big star Wars fan as a kid and I've
dressed up like Princess Leia um for TV
shows just 30 rock I was always getting
to I like to get out of jury duty I
would dress up like Princess Leia you
want to meet some perverts dress up like
got a little coup you've never met
before we'll come talk to you like it
people it's a real specific like that
yeah what so imagine so a version of
Star Wars that was never made we were
Princess Leia and Han Solo
so do they do that I love you oh I love
you getting into character hold on
firk fresh I love you
starter and yeah for sure I don't I
probably didn't see a penis until I was
at least 20 and that was probably a
medical journal so like and are you
bored of asking but if it is interesting
because 25 just came out blah blah blah
that you did co-write this this song
with Adele yes